in this video we'll talk about
retrotransposons
retrotransposons are transposable
elements which hops from one location to
another location with the help of an RNA
intermediate
it reverse transcribe this RNA
intermediate forms a cdna and then
integrates into a new location
now retrotransposons are pretty common
they can amplify themselves very quickly
that's why they are pretty much abundant
in eukaryotic genomes
you would be surprised to see that in
Maize they comprise 49 of the genome
whereas in human they are roughly about
42 percent
retro transport bosons are broadly
classified into two groups the lgr
detrotransposon and the non-ltr
retrotransposon the ltrotransposons are
virus-like retrotransposons so they are
pretty much like a retrovirus and the
non-ltrotransposons are very different
from the LTR ones they don't have a
particular feature and also they have a
polyethyl they are more similar to a
eukaryotic Gene
let's talk about the ltransposon first
now ltransposon has LTR or long terminal
repeat in both the sides inside the left
LTR there would be a promoter sequence
where the transcription can start
and also there is a coding lesion that
give rise to integrase and other enzymes
necessary for this transposition
reaction so after a successful round of
transcription
LTR
retrotransposon MRNA would be generated
so let's see how retro transposon get
integrated into the genome so the LTR
two transposon first generates the MRNA
which gets
reverse transcribed with the help of
reverse transcriptase and the cdna is
generated
also remember the cdna gets clipped up
by the enzyme integrates at the ends and
in the three prime ends there are now
open hydroxyl group which can attack the
target DNA
and that is how they gets integrated
into the target DNA later on there are
some open gaps which are filled by the
cellular repair machinery and pretty
much this is how the retroviral Retro
transposons get integrated into the
genome
now apart from retroviral or LTR
retrotransposons there are non-lter
Electro transposons let's talk about
them when we talk about non-ltrie
retrotransposon lines and signs come in
our mind Line Stands for long
interspersed nuclear element and sine
stands for short interspersed nuclear
element
signs and lines are short but they are
they are specific type of retro element
which doesn't have ltrs but they have a
polyethyl
five Prime and three prime utr which are
pretty much like uh eukaryotic Gene
so they also move via an RNA
intermediate lines and signs are pretty
important and abundant in eukaryotes
almost 34 percent of the genome contains
lines and signs
lines are autonomous
but signs are actually dependent on
lines for jumping from one location to
another
they are variable in size mouse lines
are let's say 600 base 6000 by squares
whereas human signs are some somewhere
like to 48 base pairs
simply lines are bigger signs are
smaller
now let's look at the structure of line
in bit more details or a
polyurethrotransposon in with more
details it doesn't have a LTR but they
have
specific a stretch of poly a tail which
is very poly adenylation sequence is
very common to any eukaryotic Gene and
they have that similarity they have five
Prime and three prime utr that can also
be seen in case of eukaryotes
now adjacent to the three prime utr
there exists 80 Rich sequence which
would be eventually important
the orf2 and or F1 encodes for many
proteins what if two derived RNA binding
protein and another protein which has
endonuclease and reverse transcriptase
activity is important for the function
of the line trans retro transposons
so let's see how lines get integrated
into the genome
so but before that let me tell you lines
encode for a protein which has
endonuclease and reverse transcriptase
activity and this particular enzyme is
not only important for the line to get
integrated into the genome but if signs
want to get integrated into the genome
this same protein would be used so sign
cannot produce their own proteins they
they depend on line for these kind of
reverse transcriptives or endonucleases
so let's talk about how signs and lines
are integrated into the genome so first
the line mRNA gets transcribed so
obviously
the MRNA would be produced which has
five parameter Prime utr polyethyl as
expected then the orf2 products would
bind to this mRNA and guide it towards
the target DNA generally line mRNA binds
to the
polity Rich regions in the DNA
now there is a target side cleavage RNA
DNA hybrid would be forming in this case
and in this situation
the reverse transcription reaction would
take place so the first strand of the
cdna would be synthesized eventually
both the strands of the cdna would be
synthesized later on DNA joining and
repair would incorporate these elements
into the genome this is how lines or a
non-retroviral retrotransposon get
integrated into the genome we do see a
similarity in their integration process
that means both use a RNA intermediate
but they structurally look very
different
anyway
have you ever wondered that how line
selectively transpose line mrnas and not
transpose any other mRNA from a gene X
because both the MRNA structures are
pretty same so how or F2 products
mistakenly don't integrate any other
random genes into a location
well there are there is always a
possibility but it has been shown that
the endonuclease and reverse
transcriptase enzymes has more Affinity
towards line mRNA in a sequence
dependent manner compared to any other
random mRNA of Gene X let's say so that
is how it ensures that line is
integrated into other region not any
random mRNA
so let's talk about functions of the
retrotransposon just like any other
transposons retrotransposon can lead to
several effects in terms of the genome
first of all it might have mutagenic
effect that means
a retrotransposon peat retroviral or
non-retroviral it can jump from one
location and get into another location
let's say that location is a middle of
an Exon so it would disrupt the coding
frame
it can also lead to epigenetic silencing
it can also serve as a source of long
non-coding RNA it can act like an
enhancer and thereby regulating
transcription so there are many
functions of these retrotransposons
you can get more flash cards and notes
in my Facebook Channel
you can follow me on Instagram for
further notes links are in the
description you can support our Channel
via super thanks and let's see you in
next video